it started here in 2016 outside Gibson's
Bakery in Oberlin protesters calling for
justice after an employee accused a
black student of shoplifting wine inside
the store
claims of racial profiling and boycotts
followed for weeks the lawsuit filed by
Gibson's accused the College of
supporting the protesters views the bill
must shut down the business the
university did or the campus did by just
constantly protesting after the students
were accused of stealing
by a student yeah a jury agreed awarding
Gibson's 25 million dollars in Damages
owner Lorna Gibson says the turmoil
ruined the family name we lost so much
of the business
um after the um protests that uh
we weren't getting the business and so I
couldn't afford to keep the shelves
filled eventually the three students
involved pleaded guilty to misdemeanors
saying in court the employee didn't act
out of racism
they actually stole yeah
wow yep
[Music]
you okay
yep everybody at the protest needs to
catch that l
and you better reward that money to
Gibson I'm sorry but it is what it is it
is what it is you know what it is you
know what it is that's what happened
when you just go on
and you go on a bandwagon because it
fits your uh narrative right but you
haven't checked the facts before your
room's bit you ruin businesses and
people's lives and [ __ ] that's what you
do you're going on bandwagon because it
fits exactly your night of what you want
to push for oh my God I'm Against Racism
Edition do you know all the facts were
you there no all right let's look at the
facts what happened people that will lie
do I have the opportunity to lie we'll
lie that's what this [ __ ] told
me a couple of years ago
at first I was like nah [ __ ]
will not hear [ __ ] would lie
yeah you think about it people will lie
if they need to lie to get their ass out
they will lie they will mm-hmm they're
still waiting for the school to take
responsibility it was Overland college
that can never admit that what they did
was wrong in a statement the college
said in part we are disappointed by the
Court's decision however this does not
diminish our respect for the law and the
Integrity of our legal system this
matter has been painful for everyone we
hope that the end of the litigation will
begin the healing of our entire
Community meanwhile Gibson says it looks
forward to moving past this serving
customers for the last 138 years it's
doors they say are open to everyone and
we've always treated everybody
properly and that's all we just wanted
that's all we wanted from the start just
to continue on our lives and keep the
store going so
this is where the next part comes in
there's a response from Oberlin College
this video is brought to you by surf
shark hey sometimes you want to watch
certain videos from other countries and
you can because your country is not
allowed
I know well you need to get yourself a
VPN changer a VPN changer is something
that's gonna change the location of your
computer I'm from Canada and our Netflix
is nice but it's not like the US Netflix
or the UK Netflix or anything no or any
Netflix around the world and sometimes I
want to be able to enjoy that content
well I just teleport my computer with
the VPN changer wherever I want it to be
and I can enjoy whatever content I want
and now now if you if you you go on the
link below you use the code Abba and
breach you're going to be able to save
83 and have three first month for free I
know I know go right now click on the
link below and you know let your your
computer travel
and you will enjoy all the content that
you want
and tonight we're taking a closer look
at the lawsuit between Gibson's Bakery
and Oberlin College after the college
was accused of branding the bakery as
racist and encouraging protests outside
today a Lorraine County Judge reduced
the Judgment indicates from 44 million
dollars to about 25 million dollars and
that's because of a cap on punitive
damages in Ohio this case dates back to
November 2016 when three black students
were arrested for assaulting owner David
Gibson's son Alan who was white after he
caught one of the students shoplifting
protests ensued over accusations of
racial profiling well earlier this week
we had the attorneys for the Gibsons on
this show and tonight we welcome Oberlin
president Carmen twilley Amber and
defense attorney Rachelle Cesar now mind
you the students involved who did the
shoplifting but admitted to doing the
shopping listing and there was no racial
profiling involved so they pled guilty
and basically had their stuff reduced
but they did plead guilty admitted to
stealing and it turns out they did do it
so this is the person who runs Oberlin
College speaking of thank you so much
both to you for being here thank you for
having us we appreciate it you know I
want to start off by saying president
ambar you were not at Oberlin College at
the time of this original incident when
you look back now would you have handled
things differently if you weren't and
how you know I this people ask me that
question a lot it's a complicated
question because having been a college
president for 11 years when you sit in
the seat you know that you don't have
all the facts on the ground and so now
we're looking at this incident three
years later essentially with all the
facts and so it's hard to know whether I
would have done things differently
because what they knew at the time sort
of drove them to make the decisions that
they made and we now have a different
set of information yeah that's fair
enough you guys have been very vocal in
recent days just talking about how you
disagree with the jury's decision and
also the legal principles around this
lawsuit can you explain why right well I
I will let our attorney talk about it a
little bit but I do think that this is
really about the speech of students and
whether a college should be held
responsible for the speech of students
and there's often times speech that's
permissible speech First Amendment
speech that we allow folks to make but
this is also about a claim that this was
impermissible Speech but fundamentally
did the college make it did the college
produce the flyer did the college
produced the Senate resolution and the
answer to that is no and that's why I
can have a chilling effect on speech
because what we would have to do to
constrain students and faculty and staff
just in case we might be liable for that
speech we'll be constraining People's
First Amendment rights okay so this is
where the obfuscation comes to play the
court made no determination regarding
the activities of the student they
finally the College administration in
particular Meredith Raymondo had libel
the bakery Meredith used her position to
organize the protests she's part of the
faculty and she and another staff member
were found to have handed out the Flyers
to the members of the public the Flyers
are basically denouncing the bakery say
don't go there and what they've done and
how racist was okay
photographers had testified that they
were both doing that another staff
members made copies of the flyers for
distribution Meredith also made
interference with the business
relationship by ordering the suspension
of existing orders from the bakery until
their demands concerning how the bakery
dealt with the shoplifters who also
happen to be Oberlin college students
were met basically saying like we're
going to suspend all orders from this
Bakery because this Baker's right in
front of the college until you guys
change the way so them trying to claim
that they had nothing to do what That's
my boy what's up it's not until we know
what happened with the robberies no no
no until there's a change with how
things were done with the shoplifters
okay but they did shoplift
so the college was 100 implicated so her
doing all this legal speakers her
defense attorney coaching her trying to
come up with me but it's not the facts
of the cases yes her cause she's trying
to say students have a right to free
speech that's not what the court came
yeah court case said no [ __ ] your
faculty your members were part of this
whole thing and they represent the
university when they're using company
company uh tools to make the libel right
that you're part of it they're part of
it you're part of it so to me watching
this it was very interesting
on one hand I'm very happy that one the
bakery took out some lawyers two that
they won their case and three that the
facts came out
in the end I think folks in an effort to
want to be woke or whatever it is or be
on the right side of history or jump in
the gun on something that shouldn't have
been jumped the gun on you ask any
person who's a minority and they find
out someone shoplifted they wouldn't be
here like it's unjust to charge them for
shoplifting no you stole you stole it
you also assaulted the person who comes
trying to catch you stealing
you gotta go you got to hold the
accountability for the you can catch
he's a charges you're not a you're not
10 you're not 12. you're not 14 you're
not 17 or 18. you're in college you're
three years in you're gonna hold that
out catch these charges
come on now come on I'm all for
denouncing things when they're unjust
but you were out here with your hands in
the wrong cookie jar you gotta hold that
up
so does the University like you said
did you appreciate the way that you're
trying to get away from your
accountability like that just a free
speech just has nothing to do with it
you wouldn't have flyers and then you
you printed flags and if you hang you
were there come on listen listen come on
being falsely accused of something like
that in a smaller Community such as
theirs can ruin everything
I gotta [ __ ] you up
you get looked at completely different
within your own Community you feel
ostracized you got people yelling all
kinds of stuff at you and your family
like yeah this kind of stuff is
absolutely incredibly damaging even even
for someone who was thieving and like
assault come on bruh even on a bigger
scale it's damaging remember Tommy
Hilfiger
there was a a rumor that Tommy Hilfiger
went on Oprah and said that uh he would
never allow black people to wear
is is is is is as much and that's a
rumor that was out and about
that he went to Oprah and said that and
I have people that I know that said hey
I saw the interview yeah I saw the
interview that man went there and said
that and that rumor was going through
out the 90s
and then late 90s Oprah did an interview
with Tommy Hilfiger and did you see that
one no when it's actually out there when
she asked him about it she's speaking
like where's that from
I could say and Oprah's like I could say
you've never been on this show
this is the first time I'm talking about
Mandela effect so do we do where do we
know like I don't know and the guy's
like talk
the dude was like I don't know we hired
investigators to see where it was from
we hired all this all that none of that
matter no because because the people
thought it was that and they took it and
he ran with it good let him run all
right listen let me tell you man that's
like having a girlfriend who get mad at
you because you cheated on her and her
dreams which but the Mandela effect is
real some people will like literally
brainwash themselves and thinking they
saw something that didn't happen so you
know it's one of those things but yeah
be very careful like accusing somebody
with such big labels when people call
folks in cells when people call folks uh
or when they say race or whatever it
might be or any of these words just be
careful because the more you use them
incorrectly the more that anyone who
uses them subsequently starts to doubt
the validity of the words because we've
seen it so many times just be used for
no reason that's all I'm saying this has
a negative net negative impact on
society when it comes to these issues so
yeah anything else